did you call you effinity yeah see I got
caught in the crossfires because there's
a lot of stuff that was going on
Backstage and stuff like that you know
there's a feuding between Moscow and
Kevin Holland like stuff that I wasn't
aware of and I commit to the character
and do the [__] so he was pissed off at
my question at the wrong time I asked
what was the question asked about like
Kevin Holland something like um if he
had a steel chair who would he hit over
the head with but also that was the same
day that the WWE the WWE deal merger got
announced yeah yeah so it was a
wrestling questions and I I just asked
like is he pretty serious question so I
wanted to follow a serious question it's
edited so it looks like you just came
out that way no no yeah it was my second
question
Daniel was like any other stupid [__]
questions yeah and then we facetimed on
that Tuesday Dana and I oh really
because I called him up I wanted to know
what was going on and we were cool it
was cool it was cool that's cool he told
me his side told him my side and